The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: All right.
So we're going to talk about
performance engineering and
pretty much how to do that
with profiling tools.
So first, we're going to talk
about what profiling tools are
and how you use them in
general, what the
theory of that is.
And then, more importantly,
we're going to do an
interactive walk-through
of two examples
that we picked out.
The first one is the Matrix
Multiply that you guys saw in
Project 0, the cache ratio
measurements and how to do
those measurements and how to do
the cycles per instruction
measurements, these
kinds of things.
And then we're going to look at
doing some of the bit hacks
that Charles talked about
in the second lecture.
We're going to work on a
branchless sorting algorithm,
which is pretty interesting.
So the code we gave you in
project one, it was very
obvious where the
hot spot was.
But real life doesn't really
work that way.
And code gets really,
really big.
It's not always obvious
where the part is
that you want to optimize.
And you really don't want to
waste time taking what is
otherwise understandable, good
code, and beating it over the
head trying to make
it go faster.
So that's why Donald Knuth said,
"premature optimization
is the root of all evil."
You really want to
focus on the hot spots.
So that's what profiling's
for.
It basically gives you
visibility into the execution
of your code, because it would
be too complicated to just sit
down and look at it and try
to understand where it's
spending its time.
And there are many possibilities
for where it
could be spending its time.
In 6-172 we're mostly going to
be focusing on things that are
CPU-bound and things that are
using the memory hierarchy
ineffectively.
But in the real world, a couple
of other common things
are network requests.
So if you've got your web
application, it's making a
whole bunch of AJAX requests.
It's going to be wasting a
lot of your users' time.
If you've got your desktop
application, it's hitting the
disk all the time.
That's also going to
slow you down.
I think SQL database, if
anybody's ever done web
development, they know that
can be a huge bottleneck.
So basically, the tool that
you're going to use is going
to depend a lot on what the
problem you're solving is.
But the basic ideas
are all the same.
There are all kinds of profiling
tools for measuring
these things and figuring out
where it's coming from and
where the time's going.
So for trying to figure out
CPU and memory, there's a
couple things you can do.
The first and most basic and
sort of most obvious to you
guys is you can do manual
instrumentation.
And what that is is basically
where you go in and you put in
prints and try to figure out
where it's spending its time,
what codes could you
have executed more.
Or you can be a little
bit more clever.
You can try to insert logging
calls that fill up a buffer
with checking the time and
actually doing that yourself.
And one of the big advantages
of that is that, when you
actually go into the code and
you instrument yourself, you
can cut down the information
that's coming back out at you.
If you have an intuition for
how the program works,
sprinkling little calls to
timing functions around your
code in the places that you
think matter is going to give
you maybe a better picture.
But it requires more
work on your part.
So that's the drawback.
The other kind of
instrumentation is static
instrumentation, which
is basically--
and I should say that
instrumentation is basically a
little snippet of code that
is gathering information,
gathering data about
the code execution.
So static instrumentation is
basically code that's inserted
by the compiler when you
build your code.
And gprof is an example
of this.
Basically, what it does is it
will, at the prologue and the
epilogue for every function,
insert a little piece of code
that increments a counter
every time the
function gets executed.
I think it also figures
out who called it,
that kind of thing.
One of the drawbacks to static
instrumentation is that you
have to have the source, and you
have to be able to rebuild
your project.
If you've ever had a DLL binary
blob of data library
handed to you, and you want to
know where the time's going in
that library, you're not going
to be able to instrument it.
So you're not going
to get any data.
So that brings us to the next
thing, which is dynamic
instrumentation, which
solves that problem.
Basically, what happens there
is you take the binary as it
is just before you're
about to run it.
And before you start executing,
you actually just
take a look at the code
and translate it.
And you go in, and you insert
the instrumentation.
And then you have this new
snippet of code that you then
run instead.
And so that works for
binary blobs.
And it doesn't require a
recompile, which is great.
But it introduces a lot of
overhead, because you're not
actually running the original
code, right?
You're running this translated
thing, which might be much
more inefficient.
And I guess Valgrind has a
couple of tools that are sort
of classic examples of that,
Callgrind and Cachegrind.
I think Callgrind gives
you a call graph.
And Cachegrind tries to measure
the cache effects,
tries to make a prediction of
when you do memory accesses,
are these things in
cache or not.
Another thing you might want to
look at, or the thing that
we're going to focus
on in this course
are performance counters.
And two tools to get these
are OProfile and perf.
And basically, the CPU has a
bunch of counters-- we've
talked about them-- for branch
misses, cache misses, these
kinds of things.
And this will give
access to those.
The last tool that I guess I'm
going to talk about for
profiling is heap profiling.
A lot of times, if memory's your
problem, you really want
to figure out who's doing
all the allocation.
And so these tools will give you
a nice breakdown of who's
allocating what, who's calling
them, and who can I stop
calling so that I'm allocating
less memory.
And like I said, you can find
more tools for profiling
different kinds of problems
and resources.
But today we're mostly going to
focus on perf, which is a
new tool for getting access to
performance counters on Linux.
I guess I should also mention
that, as someone talked about
in the last lecture, the way
that you want to gather data
from performance counters is you
want to do event sampling.
There's too much data.
As you execute along, you don't
want to record, OK, I
executed this instruction,
then I executed that
instruction, and I'm going to
count all the instruction
executions and then store
that data somewhere.
That would be way
too much data.
So what you want to do is you
want to sample every so often,
every 1,000th event, or some
other frequency for whatever
your interesting event is.
And basically, what happens is
that when that counter has hit
the threshold, an interrupt
will fire, and the
kernel will catch it.
And then it will record the
data that you want, the
context, like where in the
execution it was, what the
call stack looked like,
these kinds of things.
I think we've covered most of
the performance counters that
we mostly care about.
But I think it's worth
mentioning that there are a
lot of performance counters.
And you can go look them up in
this part of the manual.
They cover a lot of interesting
things, not just
the ones we've talked about,
including sleep states, power
consumption.
And if you want to look at
contention, say you have a
parallel program, and
you have two cores
accessing the same data.
If they're writing back to it,
they're going to be fighting
over the same cache lines.
And so there are counters for
things like, how many times
did this core have to go off
core to get cache line, and
all kinds of interesting
things like that.
But mostly, we're going to focus
on the cache misses,
branch misses.
I also wanted to mention that
the tool we're using, perf, it
kind of replaces OProfile and
PerfMon, which are tools that
do similar things.
I guess it's different in that
it's a unified interface to
monitoring two kinds
of events.
The first are software kernel
events, so things
like contact switches.
So how many times did your
application make a system call
and then get contact
switched out?
And how many page faults did
your application generate?
These kinds of things that the
kernel knows about, but aren't
necessarily hardware events.
And the other kind is
hardware events.
And those are sort of the ones
we're going to focus on.
We've already talked
about those.
If you want to get this tool
and try it out yourself, if
you have any recent Linux
distribution, anything with a
kernel that's less than
a year old, you can
install Linux tools.
And the command is perf.
So now we're going to do a demo
of the matrix multiply
from Project 0.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: All right.
So for the demos, I guess I'll
narrate what the code's doing,
so Reid can focus on typing.
This code should
look familiar.
All right.
Can everybody hear me?
All right, cool.
So this code should look
very familiar.
It's Project 0's matrix
multiply code,
the original version.
And it's a triply-nested four
loop for multiplying matrices.
So what we're going to do is
I'm going to switch to a
terminal that Reid
is typing on.
And we're going to run
matrix multiply.
And it takes about eight
seconds to run.
And now we're going to run it,
but have perf output some
performance statistics for it,
basically, CPU counters.
So you use -e to request
specific counters.
You can use perf list to take
a look at all the counters
that perf supports.
In this case, we're asking for
the number of CPU cycles, the
number of instructions, the
number of L1 cache loads, and
then the number of
L1 cache misses.
Perf stat.
That's better.
So it takes a little bit
longer to execute,
I think, with perf.
But it's not supposed to
be a big difference.
You can see, 8.31 versus 8.34.
So it's relatively low overhead
sampling, which is
good, because you don't want to
change the behavior of your
program when you sample it.
Important things to see.
So we're looking at this cache
miss rate, which is 18%,
almost 19%, L1 cache miss rate,
which is pretty bad.
So as a result of that, if
you look at the number of
instructions, the number of
cycles, perf calculates the
IPC for you.
We previously talked
about CPI.
But perf uses IPC, which is
instructions per cycle.
So basically, every cycle,
you only executed half an
instruction on average,
because you're
waiting for the cache.
So that's no good.
So can anybody remember from
Project 0 what you did to work
around that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You reordered
the loops.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yes.
So the before and after.
You just swap out the
inner two loops.
And we will run it again.
OK, so remember, the previous
runtime was 8 seconds.
Now it's down to 2.5 seconds,
which is a lot better.
Let's run the perf stat command
again and look at the
performance counters.
And as you can see, the IPC
jumped from 0.49 to 1.4.
So it tripled.
And if you look at the new L1
cache miss rate, it's 1%
rather than 20%, which
is a lot better.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you point to
where the cache miss rate
percent is?
Because I just see
zero per second.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Oh,
sorry about that.
So L1 D-cache loads is all of
the times that the CPU asked
the L1 cache for something.
And then L1 D-cache
load misses is the
number of cache misses.
So you divide this over this
to get the ratio, which is
basically what Reid
did over here.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: OK.
So this is a ridiculously simple
example of how to use
perf, just so that you can
see the command set.
But that's not really a very
interesting example.
So the next one that we'll look
at is actually something
that Charles, Reid, and I did
yesterday afternoon for fun.
It started, we were testing
your Project
2.1, one which is--
I don't know how many
people have looked
at the handout yet.
But it deals with a bunch of
mystery sorting algorithms
that you have to figure out
what they're doing.
And so we took one of them.
And we were running sorting.
And Charles asked, what
happens if you have a
branchless sorting algorithm?
And we said, we don't know.
So we played around with it.
And in the process, we optimized
our branchless
sorting algorithm by using perf
to generate insight into
what the CPU is doing.
And as you'll see, we generated
quite a good speed-up.
So the first thing we'll do
is, let's start with the
baseline, quicksort,
everybody's
favorite sorting algorithm.
So I'll switch over
to the terminal.
And Reid is going to run
quicksort on 30 million
integers one time, which it
says takes 4.14 seconds.
Now, let's use perf stat
to see what it's doing.
So this time, we will ask for
slightly different events.
We'll still ask for
the cycles and
instructions to get our IPC.
But we'll also ask for branches
and branch misses,
because we kind of intuitively
know that
quicksort is doing branching.
So OK.
It's doing 0.8 IPC, so 0.8
instructions per cycle.
And the branch miss rate, so
branch misses over total
number branches, is 11.5%.
That's pretty bad in terms
of branch missing.
So let's take a look
at the code and see
why that's the case.
So here's the part of the code
in quicksort where you select
a pivot recursively, and
then you loop, and
then you do your swapping.
So these branches are more
or less unpredictable.
And looking at them, there's no
way that we could think of
to get rid of the unpredictable
branches.
They're unpredictable
by nature.
So this would not be an
interesting example of which
to do branchless sorting.
So let's switch to a different
algorithm, mergesort.
So here's the relevant code in
mergesort that takes a list,
C, and two input lists, A and B.
And you merge the contents
of A and B into C by taking
the smallest element from
either A or B, putting it in
C, and then repeating that
process until the
lists are empty.
So the "if else" branches, as
the comment says, tries to
place the min of the value
either at A or B into C, and
then properly increment the
pointer and do those
housekeeping tasks so
you don't crash.
So we're going to try running
this and profiling it.
So Reid is running mergesort.
Took 5.04 seconds.
Well, the last one
took 4.8 seconds.
So already, it doesn't
look too good.
But let's try to see
what happened.
So we'll issue the same perf
stat command, asking for
branches, branch
misses, cycles.
Reid is being lazy.
OK, so the IPC is 1.1, which
is a little bit better.
But if you look at the branch
misses over branches, they're
off by roughly an order
of magnitude just
like before, so 10%.
So OK.
Mergesort is currently slower
than quicksort.
And the reason is still,
roughly, you still have all of
these branches that you're
not predicting correctly.
OK, so why branching,
and why not caching?
Well, we did some quick
back-of-the-envelope
calculations, or research,
rather.
And it turns out that in the
Nehalem, the processes that
you're using on the clouds, one
of the design changes that
Intel made is that they made
the L1 cache and, actually,
also the L2 cache faster, so
fewer number of clock cycles
to go out to the cache.
But at the same time, they also
made the pipeline deeper.
So an L1 cache miss is maybe
three or four cycles.
An L2 cache miss is 15 cycles.
By the time you miss the L2
cache, you're going out into
L3 cache, which is
12 megabytes.
And if you're sorting integers,
most of them are
probably going to be
in there anyway.
AUDIENCE: John, those are
actually hits [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Oh, they are.
OK, so misses might be a little
bit bigger than that.
But OK.
AUDIENCE: L1 miss is a L2--
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Right,
is an L2.
AUDIENCE: L1 misses.
AUDIENCE: It was just a typo.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: OK, so the next
number is probably, like,
30 to 50, somewhere
on that order.
50-something.
OK.
But a branch mispredict will
also cost you somewhere
between 16 and 24 cycles,
depending on how many pipeline
stages are actually in the
Nehalem, which we don't know.
So bad branch predictions might
just be as costly as bad
memory access patterns.
And plus, Charles is going to
go into detail about memory
access patterns and how to
optimize sorting for good
memory access.
So it wouldn't be interesting
if I talked
about that right now.
So let's optimize branching.
So to do that, we'll use a bit
hack that Charles introduced
in an earlier lecture.
So remember, all we want to do
is we want to put the minimum
of either A or B into C. So
right now, we're using
branches to do it.
But there's no reason
why we have to.
So the trick that will apply
is the XOR trick for
calculating min without
a branch.
Does everybody kind of follow
what that code is doing?
You can refer to the bit hacks
lecture later to check.
But trust us that
it's correct.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 2: All right.
I guess we can go over it.
Do I have a mouse pointer?
Cool.
OK, so inside, you're doing a
comparing A is less than B,
the value of A is less than the
value of B. And you store
either a 0 or 1 into
a flag called CMP.
And then you take CMP,
and you negate it.
So then you end up with a bit
mask of either all 0's or all
1's, depending on which
one was smaller.
And then you mask A
XOR B with that.
So this inner expression, you
either get A XOR B out of it,
or you get all 0's.
And then you XOR B into it.
So in one case, B XOR this
expression cancels out the B.
You'll just get A out.
And the other way, B XOR 0 is
going to give you B. So that
should be convincing motivation
that this is
actually a min function.
And then, once you have that,
you can do cute tricks to
recycle the flags, to do
the A++ and B++ and
so on, using CMP.
So next, let's run this code
and see what happens.
OK, so we went from 5.04 seconds
to 4.59 seconds.
And we'll do a profiling run
just to get some stats on it.
OK, so now look at the IPC.
We went from 1.1 to 1.7--
1.7.
And branch misses went down by
a factor of 10, which is
really awesome.
But overall, the performance
didn't seem
to improve by much.
Well, if you want to look at
why, look at the total number
of instructions executed.
That's that number versus
that number.
We seem to be executing
considerably more
instructions.
So to see why that's the case,
we decided to use another mode
of perf called report, or
record and then report.
So what this does is that it
logs where all of those
interrupts actually happen.
So it logs which point in your
code the CPU was executing
when these performance
counters tripped.
And then it generates a nice
report that we can call using
perf annotate.
And the top section gives you
a sorted summary, where it
shows you the percent of times
that perf caught your program
executing that line of code.
So 11% of the times that perf
triggered its interrupt, your
code was executing mergesort.c
line 32.
So let's go to mergesort.c
line 32 and
see what it's doing.
So this annotated view shows you
the lines of C-code, which
are in black.
C-code is in black.
And then line numbers
are annotated here.
And then it actually goes
ahead and shows you the
assembly instructions
that it's executing.
And it puts the timing actually
on the assembly
instructions corresponding
to every C expression.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is this
[INAUDIBLE] is
the annotated version--
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yeah, you call
perf annotate and then a
function name.
The Project 2.1 will walk
you through doing
this a couple of times.
So you'll be able to see
what it's doing.
OK, so the assembly here is
actually pretty important.
I guess everybody's taken 6004,
or some variant, where
you had to code some
form of assembly?
OK, it's a prereq.
Cool.
So Saman will talk more
about assembly.
But in this case-- or Charles,
actually, now will talk more
about assembly.
But anyway, in this case, it was
actually kind of useful to
look at the assembly.
We won't expect you to know how
to write assembly for this
class or expect you to write
high-performing assembly.
But sometimes taking a look at
what the compiler outputs can
really help you.
Well, in this case, what caught
our eye was this cltq
thing, because none of us in
the room knew what the heck
cltq was It wasn't an
assembly instruction
that you usually see.
So that caught our eye.
And we wondered what was
this assembly doing.
So we spent a little bit of
time tracing through this,
working out what the
compiler was doing.
So in PowerPoint, I pulled
out this code.
And OK, so I looked up cltq in
my 600-page Intel manual.
Yes, your processor does
come with a manual.
So cltq, it says, sign extends
the EAX register to 64 bits
and then places that into RAX.
Why is it sign extending?
OK, so let's try to
trace through what
the assembly's doing.
So here, we wanted to do comp
equals star A less than star
B. So it moves the value at
the address in register 14
into RCX and does the same
thing for register 13.
So assume that R14 and R13 are
A and B. And so RCX and RDX
are star A and star B, right?
And then it XORs ESI with
ESI, which is 0.
So it zeroes out the
register ESI.
And then it does a compare
between RCX and RDX, which is
the value at A and the value
at B. So it does that
comparison.
And then, depending on the
result of that comparison, it
writes that result out
into register SIL--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Which
is the low-byte--
GUEST SPEAKER 2: SIL, as Reid
said, is the low-byte of the
register ESI, which
is used here.
But before that, the compiler
then executes this expression
here, B XOR a, which it puts
into register RDX.
And then, finally, it takes ESI,
which contains the same
value as SIL, and then it
moves that into EAX.
And then it negates EAX.
OK, so that kind of looks like
negative CMP, right?
And then, after negating it, it
then sign extends it to a
64-bit register.
And then it does the en masse
that we asked it to.
Well, why is it jumping
through so
many hoops to do this?
Well, it turns out, when you
declare a value of type int,
you say that it's
a 32-bit value.
And the compiler took you very
literally in saying that you
requested a 32-bit value.
So it did a 32-bit negation.
And then it extended
that to 64-bits.
So it wasted a couple of
instructions doing this,
instead of just flat-out
doing a 64-bit
negation to begin with.
Now, the problem with this is
usually you don't care if it
generates one XOR assembly
instruction.
But this is a tight loop that's
called in the recursion
process for every single
merge that it's doing.
So the time that it wastes here
actually really adds up.
So how do we fix that?
Well, instead of declaring
it as int, let's just try
replacing it with long, and then
recompiler the code and
see if things are
any different.
So here we start our process
of trial and error.
So we compiled mergesort long.
And the runtime is
4.05 seconds.
Before, it was, like,
4.5 or so.
So the runtime definitely
improved.
Let's compare it.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
just to verify.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So it went
from 4.59 to 4.05, which
definitely is an improvement.
So let's figure out, well,
let's see if it generated
better assembly.
So we'll run perf record
in order to look at
perf annotate again.
And OK, once again, it's
spending 14% of the time
somewhere in mergesort.c, which
is hardly surprising.
We'll go to line 27 and,
yeah, use long.
OK, so that's roughly
the assembly.
And Reid, although he wasted
time to find it, I have a
nicely prepared screen shot of
the same section of code.
So it looks cleaner.
It loads A and B into different
registers this time,
actually, RSI and RCX.
And then it clears out EDX.
And then it does the compare
between RSI and RCX, which is
A and B. And then it
sets percent DL.
Now, percent DL is the
lower byte of EDX.
So it used a different
choice of registers.
And then it did the A XOR B.
And then it moved that
compare into RAX.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 2: OK, and Reid
actually has a longer snippet
of the code.
And the compiler, actually, now
that we told it that it
was a 64-bit flag, the compiler
realized that there's
a couple optimizations
that it could do.
So it switched around the order
of things a little bit.
And it's recycling the value
of RDX for loading, I think
it's A+ equals comp.
It's recycling the
value RDX that it
generated out of a compare.
And now, down there, it's
negating RAX as a 64-bit
number and directly using it
without that cltq instruction.
So that was kind of nice.
So in just nudging the compiler
a little bit, we got
it to produce code that ran
roughly about 10% faster,
which was surprising to us,
actually, that changing a
single int to a long
could reduce the
runtime by that amount.
So next thing that we did was we
scrolled down a little bit
more on this window.
And we looked at the
next thing that the
compiler was doing.
And we kind of caught
the compiler again
doing something silly.
So here's the code
that we were at
before, the compare code.
And now let's look at how the
compiler did B+ equals CMP.
Once again, the reason that we
stopped and looked at this
code was we saw an instruction
that we didn't recognize, SBB.
Well, we looked at
the manual again.
And SBB of R1 and R2 is a
subtract with a borrow bit.
So it does subtracting the two
arguments and then subtracting
a carry flag from that.
So OK, why's it doing that?
Well, let's walk through what
the compiler tried to do.
Let's see, where's a good
place to start?
So it's RDX in this compare.
So it compares RDX to 1.
RDX is where CMP was stored.
So it checks whether or
not it equals to 1.
And then the result of that
check is actually stored in
the carry flag, CF.
And subtract with borrow,
RAX, RAX.
Before, RAX held the value of B.
But now, since it did this,
RAX minus RAX is 0, right?
And then minus the carry flag
is either 0 or negative 1,
depending on the value
of the compare.
So once again, it generates a
register that's either all 0's
or all 1's, 64 bits.
Now, what did it go
and do with that?
Well, jump down a little bit
later on in the code.
And it ends EAX, which is the
32-bit version of RAX, with
the value of 8 in hexadecimal.
So now it's either all
0's, or it's 8.
And then it adds that
value, EAX, which
is the same as RAX--
RAX is a 64-bit version--
it adds that value to RBP, which
stored the address of B.
So it jumped through that many
hoops just to increment B by
either 8 or 0.
Now, this seems a little
bit unnecessary.
So we thought, how else could we
express B+ equals not CMP,
and try to change the code
around a little bit so that it
does the same thing, but hope
that the compiler treats it
differently.
Well, in this case, not CMP,
when CMP is either 1 or 0, is
the same thing as 1 minus CMP.
Well, we compiled a version
of this code, and then we
tried to run it.
Refreshing our memory, mergesort
minus, where we just
did the minus sign.
So we took the runtime
down from 4.04
seconds to 3.77 seconds.
And once again, this is just
from replacing a not CMP to a
1 minus CMP.
That's all the code change
that we made.
And we will look at the
annotation again, just to make
sure that the compiler generated
different code.
Rather, we were curious
of what the compiler
generated this time.
So it's roughly this
section of code.
Now, one thing you'll
notice is, because
we're compiling with--
this is already compiling with
GCC's maximum optimization
level, mind you.
So keep that in mind when you
assume that the compiler is
going to help you out
and do smart things.
So the instructions are a
little bit out of order
compared to what you
might expect.
All right, so I'll
go to my prepared
screen shot of the code.
So what did it generate
this time?
All right, so already, this code
looks shorter than the
previous one, right?
A little bit less
hairy than that.
So what did it do?
Well, SIL, once again, is
the lower byte of RSI.
So it does the compare RCX with
RDX, which is actually
this comparison.
And then it saves
that into SIL.
And now, later, it
does the XOR.
So this was the code
from before.
And then it does a move of RSI,
which contains the same
value as SIL, which is
CMP's either 1 or 0.
It moves that into RAX.
And then, later on, it uses
RAX for one calculation.
And then it also uses the value
that's already in RSI.
And it subtracts that from
register 14, which is where it
decided to store the value of
B. So that's a much more
direct way to either subtract 0
or 1, actually get just 0 or
1, and then use it for
a subtraction.
So the end result, and something
else to point out,
is that the move and subtract
commands have a little bit of
instruction level parallelism,
because right
after you set [? LE ?]
SIL, as soon as that's done, you
can execute both the move
and the subtract at the same
time, since they use the same
source register and put in
different destination registers.
And the other thing to notice
in the comparison is the
number of ALU operations.
I'll go back to the
original one.
You see negate, and, XOR, add.
So move is not an ALU.
It's not an arithmetic
operation.
But everything else is either
XOR, and, add, or subtract, or
compare, which all
use the ALU.
Now, if you look at the code
over here, you have move,
move, move, which don't
need the ALU.
And then the other or four
or five need the ALU.
But having fewer ALU
op is a good thing.
If you remember from the
previous lecture on CPU
architecture, the Nehalem,
has six execution ports.
So it can execute six micro-ops
in parallel per CPU
clock cycle.
Actually, only three of those
execution ports have ALUs on
them, so that they can actually
do XOR, at, and,
subtract, add, and so on.
The rest of them can do register
moves and a couple of
other things, but not arithmetic
operations.
So that's a good thing.
So that's an explanation of why
the code actually sped up.
Now, just as an overview of what
we were able to do, we
ran perf stat, the same thing
that we did for mergesort, or
for the original
two mergesorts.
And we made a table of the
improvements that we made.
So originally, quicksort
ran in four seconds.
And it had an IPC of 0.8
and 11% branch missing.
So when we switched from
quicksort to standard
mergesort, we increased
execution time by 20%, which
is not good.
But the instructions per clock
jumped up a little bit.
Branch miss rate is
still pretty bad.
Now, as soon as we switched it
to branchless, we got an 8%
improvement over the
previous runtime.
But note that we were still
worse off than quicksort at
that point.
But the instructions per clock
jumped quite a bit from last
time, which is kind of what you
would expect with reducing
the branch misses by
a factor of 10.
So the CPU isn't spending
extra time stalling the
pipeline, trying to backtrack
on its branch mispredicts.
And now the more interesting
thing to me is, if you look at
the two silly little compiler
optimizations we made,
switching from int to long
reduced the runtime by 11%
over the previous branchless
implementation.
And then instructions per clock
and branch miss both
didn't change at this point.
At this point, we were just
reducing the number of
instructions.
And then going from there to
changing not CMP to 1 minus
CMP reduced our runtime by
another 7% from before.
So overall, branchless
mergesorting is 10.8% faster
than quicksorting by the time we
were done optimizing, which
is a lot better than negative.
At this point, we were
still behind.
And at the end, we ended
up ahead of quicksort.
And then, overall, switching
to branchless, with all the
performance tweaks that we made,
was 33.6% better over
the branching version.
So the non-branching ran
a third faster than the
branching version, which
is pretty cool.
And that's something that
we learned at the
end of the day yesterday.
So to conclude, what did we
learn when we were doing this?
Well, I think a lot of that
applies to the PSETS that
you're doing and how you should
go about optimizing
performance on the code
that we give you.
And it's profile before
you optimize.
So before you spend too much
time just reading through
source code and making wild
guesses as to why the code is
slow, profile the code.
See why it's actually slow.
Get some performance
counter data.
Do some perf annotate, so that
it tells you what assembly or
what line of code that it's
actually spending
the most time on.
And then, optimize
iteratively.
Don't try to do everything
at once.
Do things one at a time to see
whether or not they make a
difference.
Now, before we arrived at the
not, there are so many
different ways that you could
have expressed not and 1 minus
and negative and so on.
So if you try them all at once,
you really don't know
what made the improvement.
So you've got to try things one
at a time and see what it
causes the compiler to do,
because you can see in the
previous two examples, by the
time we made that one
optimization, it wasn't just
that one assembly instruction
that the compiler ended
up changing.
The compiler, in fact, realized
that it could do
additional optimizations on top
of what we hinted to it.
So it did even more
optimizations.
But the bottom line is, you
should optimize iteratively.
Try something, and see what
effect it has before moving on
and trying something else.
And then, as much as I don't
like coding assembly, and I
don't expect that anybody here
codes assembly for the class,
looking at the assembly is
always a good thing.
Just skim through it for your
performance bottlenecks.
And try to get an idea of
what the compiler is
asking the CPU to do.
And see if there's a way that
you can nudge the compiler to
do the right thing.
Sometimes we tell you the
compiler will optimize certain
things, will get rid of
dead code, and so on.
And most of the time, that's
actually true.
But it doesn't hurt to
double-check in the assembly
and make sure that it's
actually doing that.
And the output from perf is
pretty helpful to doing this.
It's not a monumental task
of disassembling.
It does all of the annotation
and interleaving for you.
And finally, learn
through practice.
That's the only way to learn
how to do this performance
optimization.
You gain a lot of experience
from just going out
and trying the tools.
And Project 2 will have you
working with these tools.
Project 2.1 does not have
a code submission.
It's just a write-up, where you
get to just play around
with the tools on code that we
give you, so you can see how
to use the tools.
And then Project 2.2, which is
going out next week, will
actually give you a chance to
try to optimize code that we
give you, using these tools to
help you out along the way.
So with that said, any
questions about--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
a write-up.
how do you submit write-ups
for projects?
GUEST SPEAKER 2: On Stellar.
So the handouts for the
write-ups are Stellar homework
assignments.
Just upload a PDF to Stellar.
AUDIENCE: OK.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Yeah, you just
have to build the binary
with debug info.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yeah,
minus G is enough.
As long as GDB's break points
can see your code,
then perf can do it.
And it's actually pretty nice in
that, even if your code is
inlined, it can identify where
the inlined portions came from
and pull in the proper lines
of code for that.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: I think
what's really interesting and
important here is not that they
found this interesting
thing, but the process
they went about.
A lot of times, when you are
coding, you are in control.
You have very planned structure
how you're going
about doing that.
And you follow these through and
produce the code you want.
And sometimes, some pesky
bugs show up.
You go through that.
Here is, basically, you
basically let the system and
data drive what you are doing.
And when you start, there's no
planned part, saying, I'm
going to do A, B, C, D.
Basically, you look at the
results, and you figure
out what might change.
And you can go through that.
And I was actually talking with
Charles, saying, in my
first lecture, I talked
about Matrix Multiply.
It looks really cool.
Every time I do something, it
improved by a factor of 2,
50%, stuff like that.
What you didn't see is all the
things I did that didn't have
any impact on the program.
You saw this nice tree going
down there, all these leaves
that end up in dead ends, that
had nothing happened.
So if you feel like when you
go there, you do a bunch of
things, nothing happens,
that's normal.
Of course, when you tell
somebody, you're not going to
say, oh, that [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Say, I did this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], and I did that.
And at the end, it looks like
these other people are very
smart, and they're getting
through all these
optimizations.
No, they spend a lot of
time going through
these dead end parts.
And the interesting thing in
here is, one thing is, don't
trust anything.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
Intel, they have hundreds
of engineers
working at it for years.
And OK, that should be good.
Not really.
So a lot of times, it's
an end-to-end thing.
With performance,
it's end to end.
So the problem can
be at any level.
So it could become a compiler,
it could be [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
network, it can be network, it
can be an operating system, it
can be in the memory system, it
can be in the processor, it
can be anything.
So if you say, oh, yeah, that
shouldn't be the case,
probably that's where it is.
So all the time, basically,
it's interesting.
The nice thing about these
kind of tools is that
sometimes even the tools
might be wrong.
So sometimes I have been in
situations where you look have
to look at the wall clock, OK,
wait a minute, does the tool
say what I actually see
what's happening?
Because you get into very
skeptical situations.
Because a lot of times, in these
kind of situations, the
problem can be hidden in
many different things.
So that's a very good way
of going through this.
Of course, what you get handed
to you, we have set it up in a
way that there cannot be
too many surprises.
But when you're going through
a system and try to optimize
and look at performance, this is
a really good way of doing
it, because I don't think these
guys thought, when they
started, they'd be looking
at compiled
bugs or compiler problems.
They were thinking about, OK,
I'm going to do a little bit
of code rewriting
and get there.
But at the end of the day, what
they disclosed was very
surprising to them.
And it even surprised
me today.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Our plan
basically ended at row three,
as far as when we
first set out.
We had no idea was to
follow after that.
So one thing that I remember is
that some students came to
us and asked questions, like,
yeah, I tried to implement
this bit hack here,
and it actually
slowed the program down.
Or I changed my pentomino board
representation to this also.
But it didn't seem to
speed anything up.
Well, in those cases, yeah, you
need to do more detective
work to figure out
what happened.
SAMAN AMARASINGHE: So a lot of
times, the performance is
something like a max of a bunch
of different things.
So you have done something,
that's great.
It should give you a huge
performance improvement.
But something is holding.
And a lot of times, you have
to do three or four things.
And once you do three or four
things, suddenly everything
starts kicking off.
A good example is loop unroll.
You unroll a loop and say,
ha, I should get all this
parallelism.
No, because you have
some dependence.
So you have to fix that
dependence, fix that
dependence.
Suddenly, you remove
everything.
Then you get all the
parallelism and
start running fast.
So a lot of these things,
it's basically max.
You have to get all
the things right.
And so if you stop halfway
through, that means you might
be almost there, and you
are not up to that.
So that's why it just can be a
really frustrating process.
But it's kind of fun, too,
when you get there.